-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#MyWeirdRoommate
stories from you guys.
This first one is from
@hoseway.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-No, H-O-S-E.
-Oh.
-Like a garden hose.
-He says, "My roommate would
lay on the couch
"watching TV shirtless.
"He would have ranch dressing
on one side of his chest,
"cheese dip on the other,
and a mountain of chips
resting on his stomach."
[ Audience groans ]
-That's the hose way.
-That's the hose way
right there, man.
-Yeah, man.
-This one's from @karamisu.
She says, "In college,
my roommate came to me
"in a panic and told me
her snake got out.
I had no idea
she had a snake."
-Oh!
-"What do you mean?
There's a snake?"
-At 818.
-This one's from @Jacobchiller.
-Ooh! Scary!
-Uh, @Jacobchiller.
He says,
"My roommate would come home
drunk holding his shoes
"by the laces, swing them
around like nunchucks,
"and attack me
while I was trying to sleep,
yelling, 'I'm Michelangelo!'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Slurs ] "I'm Michelangelo!"
[ Applause ]
Dude.
-[ Laughs ]
-This next one is from
@audrey87024230.
She says, "If the vending
machine didn't have
"cheddar sour cream chips,
my roommate would lie on her bed
"in sadness and say,
'When the vending machine
is empty, I am empty.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I'm with the roommate.
-Cheddar sour cream chips.
-This one's from
@LakeShowFanatic.
He says, "I had a roommate
that would pour
"toilet bowl cleaner
on his dirty dishes,
"then leave them
in the sink.
"He said, 'If it's good enough
to clean toilets,
it's good enough
to clean plates.'"
-Oh!
[ Audience groans ]
-[ Imitates spitting ]
-What was on the plate?
Oh, he's doing chaw too.
-Yeah.
"Hey, if it's good enough
for..."
-[ Imitating spitting ]
Ding!
-"Good enough
to clean them plates."
-[ Laughs ]
-This one's from @jasonaland.
He says, "My college roommate
bought size 22 sneakers,
"put them in the middle
of our living room,
"just so when people came over
and saw them he could say,
'Oh, my girlfriend's
in the shower.'"
[ Laughter
and scattered applause ]
-[ Laughs ] God, what's --
Where's the win?
-I don't know, man.
-Yeah. So people --
What did he expect
the reaction would be?
"Oh, okay."
[ Laughter ]
-I guess you'd be like,
"Wow. She's really tall."
-"Yeah, oh, she's tall."
[ Laughter ]
-That was a good bit.
I kind of like it, man.
[ Laughter ]
I give you props. I think
it's -- I think it's funny.
-Yeah, you're going to do
that one?
-I think that's
a funny bit, man.
This last one here is from
@diane-kinkade.
She says, "My college roommate
tried to kill a spider
"that was on the window pane
with a hammer.
She missed the spider."
[ Laughter ]
It's like --
-[ Imitating shatter ]
-There you have it. Those are
"Tonight Show" Hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.